Israel's military buildup near the Gaza
border is vast a Land Air and sea
operation that Israel says is aimed at
crushing Hamas could start at any time
Hamas Fighters crossed the border from
Gaza and killed 1,400 people in Israel
on October the 7th the Israeli military
says it's doing all it can to locate
what it says is nearly 200 israelies
including women children and elderly who
Hamas Fighters took captive back into
Gaza so far we've notified 291 families
of soldiers killed we embrace the
bereaved families our hearts are with
you we also notify the families of the
199 hostages there is an effort and top
National priority on the issue of
hostages and we are focused on that
effort as a top National
priority experts highlight the risks
involved in an unlikely rescue before
the announced Israeli invasion of Gaza
Begins the Israeli Army has to go in to
try to get them out Hamas has an
advantage point Hamas knows that know
that territory far better than Israel
the Israeli military denied rumors of a
temporary ceasefire to allow goods and
materials into the Gaza Strip and
currently there are no such ceasefire
efforts in case anything changes we will
update the public we are carrying on
with the war against Hamas the murderous
organization in case something changes
in regard to the hostages and those
missing we will fully update the public
on X as
such Israel's prime minister called for
political unity in the wake of the worst
attacks the country has suffered in
decades the condition of our success is
Unity we should remain united we should
remain United at the level of the
national Unity government and the people
as well and I'd like to extend all
thanks to the members of the opposition
who continue to make a maximum
effort more Rockets have been fired from
Gaza into Israel as usual most were
intercepted by the Iron Dome defense
system the Israeli military continues to
Pound The Strip what you're looking at
there is the neighborhood of bate hanon
in the northeastern corner of the Gaza
Strip now according to our teams inside
the Palestinian territory they're saying
that there's potentially thousands of
civilians still living in that area
despite repeated warnings by the Israeli
military that they should move South in
order to avoid potentially getting
killed in the
crossfire hundreds of thousands of
Palestinians are being forced to flee
their homes they have no choice but to
find what little shelter they can wait
for the Israeli military Advance Charles
staford Al jazer stot sou is ra